[Music]
let's talk healing belts generally if
you want to play that role on a team
while running through PvE you can't look
past the six piece classified reclaimer
set to gets the absolute best out of the
healing station providing extra range
station health and duration the six
piece bonus even allows you to instantly
pop it back down if it gets destroyed by
an enemy but if the six district line
was all is going to talk about this will
be a pretty short video like most of the
six piece sets the way you built them is
fairly self-explanatory in most cases
the six piece bonus actually tells you
what you need to speak into so I'm going
to assume that you haven't yet managed
to complete your six piece reclaimer
built yet or maybe you're after a little
more information around the weapons and
talents with any build video I post up
you should be using these as a guide
only the intention is for you to use
them as a starting point and then adapt
into your style of play I'll do my best
to show a few different options within
the builds but you'll need to try these
out and make the choice for yourself at
the end I'll have a cheat sheet that
will sum up the build covered in this
video please let me know in the comments
if I can provide a little more detail if
you want to come back and check out this
video later I've posted a time stamp to
each section in the description I won't
be running through a ninja bite version
of this build because even using high
ends you'll be getting more healing out
of this build than you will with any two
or three piece sets that you add to it
this build consists of full-piece
reclaimer a vigorous chest and the
inventive backpack the reclaimer set is
all about the healing station the two
three and four piece bonuses increase
the range duration and it also applies
all support station mods at the same
time so while you're in the support
station your mo will be infinite you'll
be immune to all status effects and
players will be automatically revived
support stations are a constant heal
over time perfect for all PvE encounters
the reason this isn't so effective in
PvP is because most of the top tier PvP
builds focus on burst damage and the
support station just won't heal quite
fast enough to make too much of a
difference for PvP you'll need to focus
on burst healing skills like first aid
the vigorous chest grads / heal - all
healing skills so while you're standing
in your healing station which you will
be 95% of the time
you'll constantly be over heals
effectively meaning that you'll have 50%
more toughness which will counter the
fact that you'll have almost nothing put
into stamina and health but it also
synergizes really well with the
inventive pack pack the inventive
backpack increases skill power by 15%
while at full health because you'll
spend a lot of your time with an over
heal you'll constantly have this propped
allowing you to get even more out of
your skills all pieces have been rolled
into electronics skill power has been
put onto the mask kneepads and backpack
with health rolled onto the chest some
of the other skill powers could be
rolled into health instead but just see
how you go after all you will have there
over heal and you're spending a lot of
time in your support station skill hast
has been rolled onto the chest gloves
and holster with the full skill power
belt you want to be getting your skill
houses close to the maximum 50% as
possible but where a lot of people slip
up with reclaimer builds is that the
support station itself through the ammo
cache grants a 15% skill haste boost so
because you'll be spending most of your
time in that support station you don't
want to be speaking any more than 35%
skill haste into your built damage to
elites have been rolled onto the mask
and kneepads and enemy armor damage onto
the gloves and of course ammo capacity
onto the chest and backpack although
this isn't very important because mo
really isn't an issue because of the
ammo station but for lack of a better
option this is still quite handy you may
think that your weapons don't really
matter because of the lack of firearms
but with the right talents you'll be
able to do a bit of damage and further
increase the strength of your skills
here I'm using a light weight m4 as my
primary I'd recommend an assault rifle
over something close range to like an
SMG because you want to be keeping a bit
of distance between you and the npcs the
talents I'm running are talented kills
increases your skill power by 15% for 20
seconds competent weapon damage is
increased by 10% for 15 seconds after
using a skill you'll have this active
the majority of the time because of your
high skill haste this is a talent that
synergizes really well with the skill
power build and talented determined in
the third slot this is a personal
preference of mine as the healer I feel
it's important to have my recovery leg
off cooldown as quickly as possible
Plus also this will help you get your
skills back faster but if you were
requiring a bit more damage in order to
prop talented you mate
choose to instead run destructive your
secondary weapon should have similar
talents except swapping out determined
for destructive or vice-versa or if you
want to run a maximun rifle you could
use cool-headed for super fire skill
recovery here i'm using the urban MDR as
my secondary the talents are competent
talented and distracted this is my main
damage dealing weapon particularly if
I'm running a damage dealing skill like
seeker mines or if teammates using
builds that call status affects the
weapon mods I'm using are really just
anything that could squeeze out a little
extra damage but you need to pick these
based on your preference if on console
you may want some extra stability or
accuracy on the lightweight m4 I'm
attempting to gain any critical hit
chance and damage I can and on the urban
MDR and focusing more on headshot damage
as I said in a previous video if you
want it to further increase the damage
you are getting out of your skills
if using seeker mines or sticky bomb you
could instead use a lower gear score
weapon and use the talents ferocious and
destructive because it's a lower gear
score the whip and talents are easier to
unlock and the damage transfers to your
skills but in this situation I'd rather
be doing a little more damage with my
weapon so I'd recommend the weapons
mentioned earlier the first skill is a
given the support station
if this isn't one of your skills you
haven't been paying attention with the
second skill it's a bit more flexible if
you're running with a bunch of dps
players that are constantly pushing
forward you may want another healing
skill but one that will supply more in
the way of burst healing like the first
aid overdose if your team is constantly
dropping away from your station you may
get more from the defib however if your
team is running well with just the
support station as the main form of
healing you can choose to use a damage
dealing skill like a turret or seeker
months you won't quite get the damage
out of these that you would in a skill
build SPECT straight into damage dealing
skills but your high skill power will
still have these doing pretty decent
damage anyway there are a large amount
of talents that can benefit this build I
picked a couple of random ones based on
my style of play which is what you
should be doing to critical save this is
my clutch talent it's constantly getting
me out of trouble and being the healer
if you go down your team will suffer
combat medic using this will mean your
mid kits will heal your allies too
unless you get into trouble more often
than not you'll be using your mid kits
in order to assist your damage dealing
teammates if they're taking too many
hits steady hands I'm on consult and my
aim sucks
particularly since I've been playing on
PC for the last few weeks so because I'm
the healer are needing to sit back a
little from the fight I'm often sitting
and cover trying to prop talented and
precision this is a talent that I'll
often switch out if I'm learning to
healing skills this is my preference in
order to gain more damage from my
weapons but if I'm using a damage
dealing skill as my second skill I might
change it out for chain reaction or
shrapnel
other talents could include triage or
straight back as these both further
reduce skill cooldowns
the gear mods are for electronics kill
haste and one electronics kill power the
reason for the skill power mod is
because I'd already met the 35% skill
haste gap I mentioned earlier in fact
actually went a little over so rather
than losing the 1% I would have been
better off going for to electronics
skill power mods the performance mods
are support station healing speed with
these you should be getting healing
close to 20 K HP per second as the team
medic you'll often find that your team
plays a bit more recklessly because of
you your team can spend more time
focusing enemies down than worrying
about their health situation I know this
is something that every healer saves but
heal is really are the backbone to the
team this is mainly due to the team
changing up their play style when a
medic is on board but because of this
you really need to focus on your own
health first your team will become more
and more reliant on your ability to keep
them healing and reviving when needed
and it's pretty common to have the whole
team wipe if you end up going down so
for this reason you need to sit back get
kills just because your main role is
keeping your team alive doesn't mean you
shouldn't be shooting down what you can
kills will further boost the potency of
your skills so steal kills from
teammates if you have to although your
SPECT into the support station it's
going to go down from time to time with
practice you'll get better at this but
get into the habit of placing your
healing box in areas that will cover a
location useful for your team and won't
be shot down immediately if it gets low
blow it up but make sure you've
communicated this to your team because
if anyone has Ranga low on health they
might want to quickly run back to it and
get the 33% heal from the master mod I'm
actually terrible at being a healer I
have this need to be right up front
dropping everything inside I'm more
suited to DPS of tank builds most of
these how to play tips actually come
from watching my mate Cain who is our
team support player maybe you like the
idea of playing a support build but not
necessarily focusing on being a healer
in the NYX build video are going to
something a little more flexible but
hopefully you've gained a tip or two
from this and I'll see you in the next
one Cheers
[Music]
[Music]